on ira voir de mal étudiante et monsieur
henri bien sûr avec frédérique bel et
guillaume de tonquédec ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter
le pitch de l'histoire bertrand
chamerois nous raconter voilà ce qui se
passe dans cette histoire a avec un
petit verre de vodka malaisie bercot à
la cause de sa santé monsieur henry ne
peut plus vivre seule dans son
appartement parisien
trèbes où il accepte néanmoins la
proposition de son fils paul louer une
chambre à une jeune étudiante arrive à
se servir d'elle pour créer un véritable
chaos familiale et c'est une adaptation
de la pièce du même nom
alors on est content d'être là alors ça
dans mes chéris ton monte à bien
bertrand eux
je vous le dis je vous aime beaucoup
donc je vous ferai un cadeau avant la
fin de l'émission
à mascate en riffs bertand aida ouvrez
les yeux ou bertrand avait tous
m
c est ce que l on avait juste bertoua
regardez moi dans les yeux ou bertrand
est ce que vous savez que je suis un des
animateurs les plus souples
travaux découvrir mais tout ouïe qu'il
est nu et les gens mais ça me dégoûte
les gens vous voient tous mais ça va
bien toi mais non mais c'est beau on pas
l'air trop qu'est ce que vous voyez là
si vous voyez vous êtes tous à poil
mallet
vous menez guillaume de tonquédec et
plus
mais tout le monde mais bon ça passe là
ça passe encore je venais là vous allez
nous dire à jean-michel et du savon
jeune garde assez bon chéri bertrand et
des toux demi
mais oui mais il est comment tout nu et
dégueulasse non
est-ce que ça va aller isabelle est tout
nu mais en fait ça me gêne parce que
mais est ce que enfin là on tourne un
truc pour plus tard où ça le samba passe
tapas on est tout nu c'est maintenant
c'est nouveau c'est ça la téloche
maintenant c'est moi
enora vous et vous voyez sa poitrine
bah oui oui et alors c'est énorme
non mais
ça me gêne
les valenciens que je suis dit oui je
vois tu nous mais ça me met c'est beau
c'est beau les braves ont demandé 40
secondes et houston ça me gêne mais pas
de quoi vous êtes tous les cas le
meilleur oeil
regarde moi c'est pas énorme non mais on
le savait
juste à l'est tout le monde rame et duty
possiblement drôme et du tissu c'est bon
tout le monde remet du tissu c'est bon
avant d'accueillir camille combal
je voudrais vous dire des choses le
grand jeu c'est sur w9 ce sera jeudi à
raptor 55 et jusqu à cause de quelqu'un
qui croit que le monde est nuageux ccja
vous il ya ça aussi c'est énorme ce que
fait cyril cyril vous aimez il est
exceptionnel exceptionnel et j'aime
beaucoup comme garçons syrie commencent
à réellement merci c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai
un lieu unique où joue quasi ça dérange
pas
on est où là qu'est ce qu'il a c'est à
dire tout le monde trouve ça tout le
monde est à poil et sachant que c'est
normal cette fois leur entraînement vous
l'aviez déjà vu tout du nom mais habite
la cbg a besoin d'être le seul être gêné
non du tout le profil est ravi c'est ça
la téloche maintenant même dans motus
tout montre a tenu à leur attention
ailleurs bertrand rien à l'état en bio
vous connaissez qu'alain bien des fagnes
c'est aussi et cyril aussi à vous étiez
là vous l'aviez laissé un petit truc à
dire qu elle avait placé direct cette
année il a déjà assez de problèmes avec
les cheveux on va pas en rajouter non
plus oui ça marche pas mal sûr il faut
un peu de temps avant on fait là on a on
sait pas croiser avant parce que sinon
ça marche bien étudié les cas ce soir
oh bah oui a dû délivrer que ça ça
mathieu est ce qu'il ya devant vous le
trouvez lui n'a il est beau mais vous
vous êtes plus beau oui vous êtes le
plus beau des animateurs merci mon chéri
marie à la perfection
oui vraiment pardon pardon au temps pour
moi
je vous redis bertrand vous voit nue ans
chami
oui c'est un fait c'est parfait merci
c'est parfait bertrand que ziani ça me
gêne puis je vois les épilations de tout
le monde sait quelque chose
j'ai attaqué très poilu ya des gens
n'ont pu piquer
il ya tous les styles quoi voilà et oui
les chroniqueurs mes chroniques quand
j'ai la chance qu'ils aient le pupitre
devant grave vous allez quoi météo
tout d'abord un messie dit des trucs
mais non mettez vous demain mais j'ai
pas commenté les invités peuvent rester
derrière à lennik label après il croit
vraiment que la voie du mois que
s'arrachent unique elle alors sont pas
vos gueules ça il y avait à boire et à
manger quoi
c'est tout parce que rien des trucs et
faire vraiment le rap et r guillaume
guillaume et frédéric vous êtes avec non
franchement vous remarquez on peut le
dire c'est hallucinant on vient ici
russie n'a concédé dans leur sens ne pas
les contredire pourra dire s'il se poser
la question c'est y pas dans leur sens
ah bien sûr regardé complète pouet
allez on va pas la chronique de camille
comme ça vous fait les séries lui mais
on dirait qu'on est on dirait qu'on est
dans belle toute nue ça rigolait
commenté mathieu de mais il est né fait
pas une fixation
mathieu ça va bouger oui vous êtes fixés
bertrand vous le trouvez vous oui les
bobos bertrand niveau afin qu'une petite
danse à bertrand mais non mais
tapas musique à l'époque de vauban
à vos places les chéris merci travail
bertrand ça vous a perdu huit ans c'est
particulier